we're all  [Music]  in this rat race where we think if we  take a day off we're falling behind and  if we fall behind we'll never be able to  catch up when in truth like that's why i  put that tweet out that i put out that  you know everyone seemed to like that's  pinned on my thing that  life's longer than life short but it's  actually long you need to go out and  have lots of different experiences and  like david epstein talks about in range  try many many many things most of which  you'll probably be shitty at  but ultimately you'll find that thing  that lights you up  and then you'll realize by pursuing that  that all those other experiences find a  way to contribute to you becoming this  you know kind of unique actualized  person